[Music]
austin is with us
in las vegas nevada hey austin what's up
hey how are you guys doing great man how
can we help
hi so uh i'm 23 years old um
i've been working for my father for the
last three years making 15 an hour
and i'm finally moving into the career
field that i want to go into and i start
um in two weeks um i'm going to be
making double what i make now so i'll be
making
30 an hour but my question is
my uh my father says that i need to open
up
a credit card account and build credit
in order to get better i think interest
rates on how when i when i go to buy a
house
and um i i don't have any credit at all
i don't and i've been listening to you
for a little over a year now and i know
that's not
the right thing to do um but i just
wanted to know
um why not to do that and um
yeah that's my question well austin you
know why
at 23 years old you don't need any you
don't need any debt and you don't want
any debt let me put it like um second
you don't need a credit score to pretty
much a debt score
to get a good interest rate on your
mortgage okay i don't have a credit
score i didn't have a credit score
and i was able to get a solid interest
rate on my mortgage that i have for my
house just the other day
just the other day like two weeks ago um
and so
here's what you need though so let me
stop a second okay
the point is no disrespect but your
dad's just wrong
yeah he loves you but his supposition is
is that you need to get a credit card to
get a lower interest rate
anthony just told you he just did it
with zero credit score
so apparently your dad's information is
inaccurate
yes that changes the equation doesn't it
yes sir yeah man and it feels good to
have a mortgage payment with no other
debt
let me just be real with you and so also
i would definitely say just um just tell
your father hey dad thank you so much
for
uh your thoughts um i i am respectfully
um going to respectfully disagree with
you
and follow the plan that i believe is
best for me in my life but dad i love
you and that i appreciate you yeah you
can be honoring to him but
you know one of the things about growing
up is you discover that your parents
don't know everything
right and some of the stuff they know is
wrong
yeah and it's just wrong
that's it that's the only thing you can
call it it's just